What should a country do if another country
seizes one of its citizens in what looks like
hostage diplomacy? Sadly, this is not a hypothetical
question. Iran holds several western citizens on
flimsy charges. Muammar Gaddafi seized two Swiss
businessmen after Swiss authorities arrested
his son for battery. And just recently, China
effectively admitted to engaging in similar
hostage diplomacy, which is a form of gray-zone
warfare. One strategy is to do like Switzerland
did and suspend of all the visas issued to the
offending country. A more effective alternative
would be for the targeted country to suspend
the visas of selected members of the perpetrator
country's elite, including their families. Remember,
the children of the elite often live in the West.
Another strategy would be a luxury goods embargo.
Suspend exports of designer brand clothes, shoes,
bags, and jewelry. It, too, would primarily hit theelite.
Yes, designer clothes have nothing to do with
hostage diplomacy, but in the gray-zone,
the key is to respond with surprising moves.
Some of the ideas presented in this video
are from my new book, The Defender's Dilemma.
To learn more, check the links provided. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.